que ton père était alcoolique comme cas
woerth c'est vrai ça marche puisque
c'est vrai nom et buvait comme un trou
et il était violent
tous les jours ils tabassaient et on
était content que tu cognes à carreaux -
pendant ce temps il pensait pas à le
traîner devant son atelier et quand on y
allait dans son atelier il nous
demandait en se marrant tu te mets à
genoux et une des boutons de toi même
uche qui l'obligent à qui ça tu as
forcément moi j'ai fini par me blinder
mais ma ale reagan pardon je suis désolé
je regrette je te vois j'étais
absolument pas au courant je t'assure
c'est vraiment la bonne histoire et
c'est du pipeau je sais jouer moi aussi
un connard me chercher à ma tuque
revient étant un peu cinglé français sur
cinq travaille avec reagan personne
c'est comme maxi avec un singe alors il
est bon c'est possible c'est sa trachée
ton costume d'oiseau à perdre elle est
tombée